welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse this is Philip Alena and this show
is the big question it's a show that
gives you too much information if they
question our dub big question we need to
decide that question us what it should
be and then we'll make a decision
hey look folks the marvel cinematic
universe may be fictional beat you guys
to us it's very very real and it's very
deadly and according to Philips research
it turns out someone you know is likely
a Black Widow and she's already on her
way to kill you that is exactly what I'm
saying
under saying get out of the house Martin
your life depends on you watching this
episode hopefully we don't get too drunk
before telling me how to see something
and say something too late too late hey
Philip our question day comes from at
Beaman Beaman do black widow super spy
assassins exist in real life
I'm beaming demon that song is playing
in your head before you told me what you
were doing got the lady scream and
screaming Oh demon demon our Black Widow
super spy assassins real okay so I had
to break this down because our spies
really yeah duh a Black Widow
super spy like that is such a narrow
target to hit of what this level of Spy
is what route they've gone through so I
broke it down over a bunch of different
adjectives undetectable gorgeous
brainwashed Red Room super trained
female assassin do they have to be all
gorgeous that's part of the question
there's not a more linear assassin who's
just waiting for me out well they're
kind of is in my research will had a
killer but are those level real and it's
it's kind of interesting like where
they're the routes went throughout
history obviously the actual Black Widow
program is inspired by the Winter
Soldier program and the success of that
but there's that's all based on like the
success of real spy stuff so let's go
one adjective at a time I got it okay
okay one first of all undetectable spies
the best example of that is a
undetectable KGB or Russian spy is
what's known as the illegals program
which you might remember from the
American American the
best shows and love that show the
Americans is great in the Americans
that's set in the Cold War
it's the idea there the sleeper agent
cells and they're a simple husband and
wife very normal seeming very Keri
Russell ask and they have kids but no
one knows they're actually a secret
spies the crazy thing about it seven the
80s the height of the Cold War the true
story of the illegals
that really did happen where they caught
ten of these people living with the
United States happen all the way back in
June of 2010 yeah I was gonna say I feel
like it was recent ten years ago less
than ten years ago is what the actual
story that inspired the Americans so
what these people did these 10 people
the rakaat a number them that a lot of
them came through Canada they said they
were Canadian what they've done is
they'd stolen the identities of dead
Canadian children so you remember doing
that oh and then they created new lives
in the u.s. under those names Eric we
actually know a little bit about what
these people went through in their
training because one of them wrote a
book the woman who can keep secrets in
it they cover the training to
specifically be undetectable they
specifically learn how to be very good
actors like Academy Award winning uh-huh
so ScarJo oh right uh yeah exactly
double uh the study long hours of
language training specifically language
without accents okay they learn how to
speak and write in code so no one can
tell when they're sending messages they
specifically learn how to evade all
surveillance so they can avoid cameras
whenever they're traveling and this is
my favorite part of what the training
these people are under it's called just
fitting in training what they did is
they created an American town in the
Ukraine that is all American style
houses American style businesses they
could only speak in English they could
only drive American cars which is not
realistic to America right and they had
to follow American traffic laws on these
streets uh speaking to used to only
watch American movies they came to know
the town as coca-cola city oh I love it
I love it it's like their Epcot but
their actual rules applied so there goes
the baseball coca-cola mmm yummy Hooters
wings the base wings democracy and they
vomit because that's more food than
they've ever had in their life yeah they
steal it and bring it home to their
family I hope
so undetectable absolutely it happened
recently it's not the first time it's
not the last time honestly it's gonna
happen yeah these are the ones we know
about
yeah they're truly attractive exchange
for four agents that we had in Russia so
there was a trade to get in these ten
but probably have been more this program
started a long long time ago - so these
are just the ones that we know about
from that one safe floor for ten
Americans are worth two point five
don't do the math on that okay so
undetectable yes absolutely those are
real gorgeous women that are
specifically made into these spies so
the woman who wrote the book that we're
gonna keep secrets she actually says no
the ideal illegal candidate is
specifically not attracted these movie
stars stand out on this exactly and she
said that they were trained that they
should not stand out in any way here's
the bad news for her that's probably
just what they told her to be nice no
because then the exact same group of ten
illegals was Anna Chapman this is the
famous like looky-looky what you cut on
your cookie a female assassin Anna
Chapman or Anna Kushi anko actually
looks like Black Widow look at this
picture of her she's drop-dead gorgeous
she has since now she's been outed she's
a real-life model now she's appeared in
Maxim and those the pictures are sweet
you can tickle is a very high standard
yeah and Russian Maxim I've been
rejected from Exim so many times it's
not easy we still never he won't even
let you get a subscription she's huge on
Instagram now you can check out here
like five hundred thousand followers on
Instagram she's drop-dead gorgeous and
she's of the exact same group of these
women so she probably hadn't seen her
what were they known about her they can
have one they can have one hottie yeah
the rest just noise just average normal
everyday looking folks so this is the
part that's important it actually is
likely they have more than that because
the Russians basically came up with the
idea of what's called a honey trap got
your hand stuck in a jar and I said just
look good honey no well not like honey
uh mommy Pooh Bear
these are our people who are
specifically you they're usually women
there's very attractive and they're
specifically placed to attract men and
women get them very close and in steal
items or information from them as soon
as they get close and a chapman's
specifically right when they did this
and they they caught all of them
reportedly was getting very close to
someone in the Obama administration
there's one of the reasons supposedly
why they pulled the trigger when they
did the reason that we also know this
goes further back they were known to be
very active in the 1960s in DC in the
sex clubs of DC with Fisher sixties yeah
well specifically there's a restaurant
on G Street near the White House that
you can probably still visit it was
known that if you go there you're gonna
be susceptible to specifically what's
known as comprar mat which is
essentially compromising material
blackmail material
it's what the PP tape the supposed to
trump PB tape suppose you know wasn't
like oh there happen to have recorded
Trump's it's time with those women those
women would have theoretically also been
Russian assets and purposely got it
we're not saying we're not taking any
stay on that what I'm saying we say men
though you can tell you they do exist
you know that's where they would come
from so Erika I know you're wondering
can men be honey pots to please because
you can't just be women cuz that Maxim
is gonna say no to me someone's gotta
say yes and so I want you to know that
for your own just for your own knowledge
you have to know that yes men can be
honey pots too yes they can be effective
and I know that because we did it to you
earlier wait what
editor John and I created a elaborate
plan and it's okay it's everything to be
fine Derek but I had editor John
honeypot you earlier when he was asking
you if you wanted to join him to go see
John Williams speak about rights of
Skywalker I'm doing like a Q&A with John
Williams for Raisa Skywalker before
awards season that my roommate can't go
so if anyone is interested I I blushed
and I my heart fluttered a little bit I
wanted to go but I know you flat-out
rejected him he was creating a
distraction of a honey pot variety in
order for me to steal your wallet what I
use this too
minor purchases that will be arriving
throughout the day don't people have
money in my wallet I tell so many people
I do not carry cash you can have this we
already have a copy my global entry
exactly you're an ambassador someone
else is gonna not wait in TSA lines now
do honey pots work for the sexy variety
yes they work yes they're absolutely
real they specifically have designed
this as a system for decades and clearly
it still fools you I mean but editor
John is where do you take this out of my
pocket I'll never tell you'll never
trust John again great okay yes they can
be sexy women and yes they're
undetectable right but those are just
spies we're talking about stealing
information or or items or something
black widows are more than that they're
straight-up assassins right yeah they
can kick your ass
so are there Russian assassins that are
specifically trained by the government
yeah thanks so much yeah absolutely
there's so much evidence of it but
they're very famous actually for not
doing flashy assassinations they're
famous for do you know what kind of
killing no poison oh right they poison
their enemies the very famous one is the
former KGB officer Alexander Litvinenko
and back in 2006 I think it was like
with polonium or something but they do
it all the time it's always some BS
story of like it's weird that the father
and son in two different cities ate the
same bad arugula like they have like in
all these BS answers but it's it's very
clearly poison here's what's fascinating
it's not just like yeah they do it
sometimes there's this guy Roman Dubrow
Kotov who's outed a bunch of these
assassins and these assassin groups for
Russia he'll will probably be dead soon
but with his work and other things just
this past October the New York Times
identified there is a specialized group
of Russian operatives known as unit two
nine one five five their main task is to
kill people around the world the only
big difference between them black widows
that we know of is that they
specifically keep using poison to do it
but here's how like into poison they are
the FSB which is like a officer to what
the KGB used to be
has a literal poison factory outside of
Moscow there are armies of scientists
there that have developed chemicals and
biological weapons specifically for
individual attack like for one person
they've had poison they've made poisons
that make death look natural by they can
trigger a fast-acting cancer they can
give you a heart attack other fatal
illnesses they also have drugs that make
you feel sad and crazy and then one day
make it look like you've killed yourself
everybody believes it because you were
acting sad and crazy before it that was
on the Americans right they tricked ya
yeah and in real life okay they even
tried to replace someone's viagra with
poison because he was known to use it
very frequently you could die yeah I
think I still want it though well that
was my next question is can he make me
feel loved yeah for a moment so yes they
are there are assassins too right so we
have undetectable sexy lady assassins
but poison isn't really black widow
style right we've seen like well the
spider it's her style but sure exactly
but the very things that we've seen has
definitely been double loaded guns there
are assassins that are Russian that
specifically use guns we actually don't
know much about it those crimes aren't
as strategic that's actually when
they're okay with it being Messier so
somebody that they kind of don't care
how this guy gets killed and they'll
just put him on a list to be killed sure
but a Russian assassin very recently
came out just as dum-dum he just came
out and explained how it worked it was
only paid $5,000 so he's not something
like super high level rich killing Eve
style assassin he was given a list of
people that needed to be killed each one
of them was referred to by a flower code
name there was Buttercup and rose and
Lily and whatnot
they gave him guns with silencers on
them so that part was real they called
the guns watering cans and then he got a
text message one day that just said the
rose must be picked one day huh and so
he went and shot just some electrician
at work but the guy said tonight I
committed no crimes or something like as
soon as he got shot so people are like
wait I committed no crime and
electrician was up to no good a weird
thing to shout out all right to the
electrician's family uh but they are
watching so sorry so yes absolutely they
use guns they just try to be
or slick than that usually which makes a
lot of sense so then we have that to add
to yes we have the assassins who use the
guns right with silencers even the super
fighting skills that black widows are
specifically known for we see the great
moves in the trailer we see that leg
move the the her occur on ax I feel like
I can do that too with enough practicing
I cuz it's like a wrestling move I could
figure out I could do it her Acronis the
thing where she like flipped it upside
down or like snapped me
yeah I feel like I could I feel like
it's possible how many times you need to
watch the video well I've seen it like
ten times alright already yeah just give
me like five more times I feel like I'll
break it down step by step in figure out
I'll give you five more times and then
I'll let you try it on me okay okay yeah
but you should okay let's do it yeah you
serious yes all right cool we can do it
here it's dangerous there's live wires
and I'm sorry if I'm live animals it's
like you can't pinch my answer because I
died let's do it okay I feel like we've
been through something yeah that was a
mistake don't do anything at home I did
pretty good I didn't I did great I fell
on a couch and I'm injured we were I was
in the middle an answer sorry get back
to your answer super fighting skills oh
yeah we covered a bunch of stuff they
can be sexy and undetectable and killers
on thing check super amazing but do they
have super fighting skills the KGB
invented their own fighting cell force
of course it used to be a big secret now
it's not really a secret but it's called
sistema or the system and it's this
combat method that specifically focuses
on hand-to-hand grappling and being able
to quickly disarm someone of their
weapon honestly it's not too dissimilar
to like Krav Maga or something where the
idea is do not be flashy do not do what
we just try to be very simple
immediately a pressure point and then
what I bought I bought yeah I feel love
again they can take you down very
quickly and effectively even better than
the
yes they are super trained now it's
gonna get like pretty narrow because
we're talking about the Black Widow
training specifically so now we're
talking about like the Red Room
situation where we know that a lot of
Natasha Romanovs biography is based on
her time in the Red Room what she went
through there so is there anything like
a Red Room and specifically like it's
all women they had that weird ballet
training it was a really intense stuff
right they go through yeah what they're
kind of is a version of the Red Room
because of people that have since
changed sides it defected yeah exactly
so this one was specifically referenced
to from in the 90s we don't know where
it is now but this is the one that was
there in the 90s there was an academy a
near Moscow known as the Institute to
train them first of all for
counterintelligence and investigation
they learned how to fight shoot martial
arts hand-to-hand fighting yada yada but
they also specifically learned the arts
of seduction it does come back so they
did purposely make it an all-girls
school for learning to be a spy and
seductress yeah it was kind of like a
brothel is that where you lay all
seduced I think you you pay to get
seduced at a brothel so input and paid
brothel out of undergrad brothel
university never a good idea to strip to
pay for college yes they had one of
those in a league of their own to that
finishing school it's exactly like a
league of their own and then they
misunderstood a lot about that movie
he's torturing them with his long piece
so they made these professional honey
pots at the time it is specifically they
actually were doing as recent as 2013
they were talking about they entrapped
diplomats from this specifically what
was referred to as a sparrow school
which is that some familiar at all those
Reds bear bird yeah but red Sparrow was
that movie that everybody's like that's
exactly like Black Widow there's a black
widow it is kind of arrows based on the
real thing but the sparrows schools
especially in the 60s and 70s of Sparrow
state schools where women were trained
in these spy arts [ __ ] okay so the
school exists right so then they're also
brainwashed like Winter Soldier kind of
and we see we've seen the instances of
the brainwashing there
I'll say flat out before I even like
dive into this an ex-kgb agent this is
an exact quote of his absolutely I was
totally brainwashed so that's an ex-kgb
a break like cult brainwash or like my
question like or maybe he's he's also
saying kind of like oh yeah I didn't
know what I was doing I was like
brainwashed all right so do they
actually have like brainwashing
brainwashing has we understanding is
brainwashing real right is it really a
real thing officially this is like not
BS if you have you probably maybe even
heard of this before the MKULTRA program
sure yeah it is absolutely a real thing
they tried to destroy the files when
watergate happened because they thought
these files were going to get out they
didn't destroy all of them there's a
freedom information act thing that came
out and it showed we a hundred percent
gave LSD and other drugs to people that
were not just like government agents but
those are included to prostitutes
homeless people prisoners all kinds of
people to see specifically if they could
be brainwashed they were also there was
sensory deprivation hypnotism
electroshock all kinds of things often
without the people consenting at all and
it was because we were trying to make a
super soldier from the CIA at the time
trying to brainwash absolutely is the
thing specifically the Russian version
of brainwashing is that a thing it's
actually a weirdly different thing than
both the Nazi and us ones that are
trauma based the Russians came up with
us of course it keeps coming back a
seduction based brainwash that they
apparently yeah you're excited to see
someone so well they just become putty
in your hands kind of the ideas they
become a slave to you but what they all
are combining with it is several hours
but only hours of one-on-one contact and
chemicals and hypnosis and then they
were able to produce slaves who if they
survived because of all the chemicals
could also seem to possess astonishing
physical fitness and mental focus based
on the goals provided by the programmer
they would behave beyond their normal
breaking points because they were
effectively brainwashed through
seduction somehow logistical fitness so
like they'd get like Berserker strength
like basically you can lift a car off a
baby people call them KGB zombies
and they didn't need much sleep they can
function on 20 plus hours a day without
sleep they supposedly made brainwashed
super soldiers oh my god is there such a
thing as an actual black widow super
soldier assassin sexy lady agent out
there honestly probably there at least
was in the last 50 years someone who fit
all of these things so they're out there
also watch killing Eve it's a very fun
show yeah she's kind of one of them well
that's a very complete answer and I
don't know how I'll be able to sleep at
night and especially if you live in the
DC area because that's where they all
are well we will be right back with some
more bite-sized questions and I'll take
care of after a quick message from some
people we care about
hey guys Eric here things get pretty
bold here her on the big question and
really we would love to take YouTube's
parental restrictions to the limit but
unfortunately some films they're just do
violent for us to go into all the great
detail on police publicly on this
channel so new rockstars is now offering
monthly bonus videos exclusive to our
generous patrons with unlisted links
that you can get by becoming a patron of
new rockstars Digital Studios this month
we broke down the Kingsmen Church seen a
frame-by-frame here's a clip of our
breakdown and if we get another sneak
cut on the digital zooms that we are
back to Colin Firth here for the most
crucial acting moment of this entire
sequence see the explosion causes
momentary deafness Harry's ears are
ringing and the freebird music fades
down for a moment and Colin Firth ever
so slightly shifts from berserk rage to
awareness shock confusion horror because
the ringing eardrums have blocked out
that simcard signal then the rain fades
away
Freebird comes back and he slips back
into berserk rage you can access this
plus all the other great bonus videos
we've made by becoming a patron a day at
patreon.com slash new rockstars and
thank you to all of our lovely current
patrons some more bite-sized questions
that I'm gonna tackle
fire away Philip I first went through
use from eken ray yes
why did red skull call Gamora daughter
of Thanos
if Gamora totally hated him as a father
figure and he definitely wasn't her
biological father so in what way is he
her father you know that's a good
question there's a lot of mystery
what Red Skull called them when he met
them so you called Thanos son of a Lars
he called Gamora daughter of Thanos and
then when Hawkeye and black widow showed
up called Hawkeye son of Edith and
Natasha daughter of Ivan and that was
the whole thing she didn't know who her
father was and people thought it was
freaking out
yeah I've on Vanko and then a son of
Edith is interesting because in the
comics plane Barton's mother
Edith Barton was abused by his father so
it was more like oh he was more his
mother's son than his father's son so
getting back to Gamora here even though
Gamora hates Thanos and even though
Thanos is not her biological father he
was he kidnapped her and made her like a
child soldier it shows I think Red Skull
is able to peer into your soul and
determine which parent which parental
figure you have taken the most from in
your own development and you were most
similar to so in that moment it's a it's
a scienter development for Gamora it's
telling us that even though Gamora was
taken from her birth parents she over
the years has become truly a daughter of
Thanos and her behavior and also it's
interesting because when she was brought
back from 2014 and brought back to the
present day it's interesting in that
deleted scene she doesn't take Annie for
a Tony Stark she walks away because it
reminds us that even though she's a nice
person she's on the dish it's a good guy
she's one of the guardians of the galaxy
she ultimately is one of Thanos's
minions and she has that dark side to
her so I think that's what the infinity
war screenwriters were saying by calling
her daughter if they especially that's
that whole areas about the soul stone
right so it's like which figure had the
most effect on her soul right whatever
any fool can be a dad it takes a real
man that's right and it sets up the idea
of that emotional break when Thanos does
sacrifice right right okay cool
next question is from Joel Stoffer he's
asking if Disney Plus just loses their
minds for some reason and decides to
give you Erik Bosse opportunity to
produce your own series around any Star
Wars character who'd it be hmm okay my
answer a long time ago used to be Boba
Fett but I feel like we're kind of
checking that Mandalorian now so think
you there's a character Quinlan vos that
I feel like I kind of have to exports
gotten a run on the Clone Wars he was
just one of these like Legends
characters who was in the background of
the Phantom Menace in sebulba's cafe and
then they they gave him this whole
backstory because they do that with
everybody and then he had a limited run
he was alias secured as master he's like
a Jedi's badass so if not him I would
love to see a young Lando series like
Donald clever Lando when l 337 because I
love Phoebe Waller bridge and I think
the two of them are hilarious and I
think that would be a great series but
like like a kind of sexy like 60s 70s
vibe sure yeah they're weird yeah I mean
this is it was like the best part of
solo and I it'd be a very fun one
especially because it could lean in to
give the comedy yeah it would just be
kind of a rom-com that's very cool all
right and then finally I can't believe
you picked someone who had the same last
name as you Austin W underscore 110 this
is the person on Twitter who wants to
know does kylo Ren have any naturally as
you would want to know
turn-ons or fetishes oh well let's think
about I know that's sure let's well the
thing that comes to mind for me a lot
because how would we know how would we
know leather leather he there was that
weird moment in the force awakens when
after Chewbacca shot him with his bow
caster he smacked his wound he hit it I
think I see where you're going there's
such thing called masochism which means
you get off on feeling and receiving
pain is that what he was doing does that
work punching her wound no it does it
inch me you really hard hard that's as
hard as I want to pinch anything okay
that's why I knew I knew that was a
mistake
no oh yeah that's a I mean it's
certainly a lot of sensation I mean when
asked about a JJ Abrams Adam driver I
don't think they've given an answer for
it but he's gonna say it's my fed some
the kind of in Kanan answer that kind of
makes sense is cysts get more energy
from embracing their anger their rage
their pain so you
feeling pain in that moment it was right
after he killed his father so by hitting
himself in that wound it was kind of
like a power-up moment like yes yes make
myself more angry feel that pain so I'm
kind of reading myself a battle it's
almost kind of like the henry cavill
pump pump mission possible yeah you
could I don't know if he got off on it I
mean it's it's a Disney movie so we
don't know but I did kind of look up
apparently there is pornography in the
Star Wars universe those huts are some
real horn dogs there no we've seen that
yeah he has he has all these sexual
pornographic interesting it's Twilight
dancers on chains Leia and chains and
slave clothes well remember you see when
she kills him and she took some he says
choke me harder daddy might have a
bondage King we don't know I looked this
up off his tongue yeah yeah yeah well
now we know what that means in hati's
according to the Star Wars fandom page
Belle Dorian had a formidable library of
Huttese pornography and once employed
the hollow fakir leeches worn to retai
panned edited retake and edit wait which
part is weirder like like make it again
like somewhat agree film it like this
like what he has to play all the parts
like be kind rewind yeah
[Music]
well I hope that's that's the most I
could answer that one I hope it
satisfies you Austin but not in the way
no in the way that you want let's move
on quickly to some fan mail questions
these were the ones sent in by you guys
reminder that you can mail us whatever
you want at RPO box
address is below and we'll read this
mail aloud on the show whatever it is
whatever it is our peal box is lonely
but it found stuff sweet well okay it's
RPO box bull haters this person wants to
know why does NR use click Beatty
thumbnails I'm actually really glad that
someone asked this question too actually
this is like thing because people get on
us a lot I think you're referring to the
big red arrows and the thumbnails the
big red circles sometimes some
provocative words that just feel a bit
clickbait the internet it's kind of
decided what clique baby means
specifically arrows and circles has one
answer yes Philip and I have talked
about this a lot and I think neither of
us are totally crazy about the aesthetic
of a big red arrow we agree it feels
kind of like label II it feels a bit
like like a l'heure well so everyone
else has done it has ruined red arrows
and wrinkles what we try to do what we
try to hold ourselves to is we never
want to lie with our thumbnails
everything that we point to or circle or
highlight is like the kind of thesis
question of the video you're about to
watch so yeah it did get you to click on
it did it bait you yeah but it wasn't a
bait and switch there are so many other
channels I won't call them out who kind
of do this they're so lazy about it they
will just put a red arrow 20 to nothing
and then put like a random number of
Easter eggs and like 47 Easter eggs in
this in this video
there aren't 47 of anything in the video
but they just do it instead look a choco
baby because the whole video that is a
true lie so when people see us do it
they assume we're doing the same [ __ ] to
be clear we get that comment a lot like
oh I can't stand how you always have
arrows pointing to nothing in your
thumbnail it's never that I've always
almost want to reply to those people go
look at executives point do you go watch
the video you will find a moment that
was brought up in the thumbnail it's
like our absolute minimum we refused to
make any videos that don't actually
feature that moment in the video yeah I
mean if we could get as much like expose
with our thumbnails by doing something
more aesthetically pleasing if you have
ideas send it we will definitely swap it
out if it works as well unfortunately we
didn't create these rules YouTube's
algorithm created these rules they give
you this limited little thumbnail that
most people are seeing on this mobile
which is about the size of a postage
stamp Rashmi yeah
and like you have that much bandwidth
and then their algorithm works as such
to where the most flashy
attention-grabbing thumbnail is the one
that they're gonna put at the top of
their algorithm so that people can even
find it when they're looking for stuff
and I'm gonna give you an answer that it
has a lot to do with the thesis of the
channel this channel is all about the
the things that you missed and caring a
lot about the properties that we do is
so specifically the arrows and circles
side of it the things that you missed
I've racked my brain I've talked to you
for hours about I've talked to so many
people about it the concept of pointing
out something that you've missed and
that being the concept behind the
channel but also maybe specifically like
a breakdown video that concept is not
better illustrated in any other way than
taking us a brain that you're familiar
with and showing you something you
literally are missing in it yeah while
you're looking at that if that specific
tactic is is the best that we've seen of
that that's the thing if you can find a
better way to do that I'm super down for
it to explain to someone that the
content of this video is about the
things that you did not notice right if
you can do that I'm we want to hear it
for sure we're definitely always willing
to improve but unfortunately there's
just too many bad actors out there who
are just bad actors mean like people who
make videos who are just super lazy
about it who have just ruined that
aesthetic so that anyone who tries to be
honest in their use of it just looks
just as bad let's move on doing it well
that was a fun one yeah I need to give
an answer to it yes yeah what is Philips
workout regimen that's a question what
do you think I do I think you flip tires
and that's it you just you go outside
and you flip tires every day in a
different role your way to work I do
just lift mostly but I do it at a very
fast pace one thing to the next to the
next to the next so my heartbeat is
always between 140 and 60 beats per
minute even right now and I'm working at
all times I'm always very stressed that
is honestly the best way that I've been
able to keep fat down feel free
mail your questions about my fitness
regimen which is getting up from the
couch between episodes of Clone Wars
sleeping entire well you have to try to
pay rent and then the last fan mail
question I'll do oh I like this one
though have you ever catfished anyone
well I have and you know this story yes
if it's one I'm thinking about have it
Bend oh I don't know which one you're
quickly I both been catfished and I have
catfish I feel like it's the Millennial
right message in hi sit wasn't like the
show MTV catfish which is my guilty
pleasure I love that show
there was a girl I had a crush on and
she had a crush on another it was the
classic Shakespearean situation I
murdered my father that's three I knew
that she had a crush on him because I
was you know I was on a I am aim and I
was like talking to her somehow I was
able to figure this out and I looked him
up he was not on aim so I created a fake
account of him ah name and then message
requested her and pretended to be him
and would like just kind of like be mean
to her what go team I didn't know how to
I thought that was flirting but like it
kind of like worked because like she had
a question of any kind of attention
she's nagging it was an I was Megan but
I didn't it was before Megan had a name
to it and then and then we're all in a
play together and she would try to talk
to him in person and he would just like
blow her off so then I would go in there
at night after a day and he's like we
really tried to explain it and then
eventually I could on opening night I
confessed to her that it was me the
whole time thinking it would be like oh
I thought like all this time I love was
directed to you and I thought it would
be great and she goes oh I think you
were gay yeah so you guys didn't work
out later we went on a spring break trip
to Europe and we whoa oh my god I gotta
wrap this up we pretended it was
somebody else why does your mind go
there I'll say really quickly
i catfished everyone everyone in high
school
I'm also on AIM so easy I just create
endlessly I also pretended to be the
University of Central Florida and I sent
a bunch of friends over go in there
rejection that was on April Fool's
that's that's exactly when you find out
is like the first years so mean um but
they all got in because it's kind of
easy to get into school for this episode
of the big question and remember it's
the show that gives you too much
information normally these horrible
truths will help you stay alive live a
few years longer and not get catfished
using AOL Instant Messenger paper a
reminder to send us your big questions
on twitter using the hashtag big
question or mail us at our p o-- box
address and subscribe to new rock stars
here on youtube and for audio versions
of the show subscribe to the big
question wherever you get your podcasts
if you haven't already check out
episodes from previous weeks
we had sir question like how many people
does whole kill when he claps his hands
good Palpatine you can follow us on
social media a da boss and at Phillip
Malina and subscribe and follow a new
rock stars on all social media as well
at me rock stars see you next week don't
do the leg thing again
[Music]
[Music]